and welcome to Hannity and breaking
tonight Joe Biden is finally back at
your white house after lounging on the
beach for the last 10 days and your
part-time president has finally returned
to the Helm of a country frankly
crumbling around him coming up we're
going to have the very latest on the Joe
Biden bribery Scandal allegations they
are very real it is unfolding every day
including newly uncovered ties to the
Obama Administration also check in with
the house speaker and house Judiciary
Committee chairman Jim Jordan will be
here with a lot more also we'll get
reaction from clay Travis and Tommy
Lauren on the U.S women's soccer team
which just suffered a humiliating loss
at the World Cup of course after
prioritizing their far left woke
politics over playing soccer and tonight
we will get reaction from the heir of
Anheuser-Busch to the entire de la
Mulvaney controversy Howard the founders
of Anheuser-Busch feel but first let's
head back to the White House where
earlier today the president was
celebrating another sports team the 2022
World Series champion Houston Astros
that's right after 10 days at the beach
where he could barely move his beach
chair and really needed a t-shirt on
Biden's only real event today back at
the White House was a lighthearted
celebration and even that was a struggle
for your 80 year old cognitively
impaired commander-in-chief take a look
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
I got him man worst part bars I remember
rooting for him as a kid and I was older
than he was
because it wasn't easy people counted
you out saying you're past your Prime
hell I know something about that
[Laughter]
all right after rambling on and on for a
few minutes Biden looked very Dazed and
Confused before daughtering out of the
room taking of course zero questions
along the way as per usual this as
serious crisis now are now emerging both
at home and abroad for example we are
watching and have our eye on China
tonight they are now capitalizing on Joe
Biden's weakness we already know that
the bidens are well potentially even
likely compromised when it comes to
China after a major Chinese oil and gas
company cefc allegedly we now know sent
Millions to Hunter and Company after
Hunters threatening WhatsApp message
saying I am sitting here with my father
his best impression of Vito Corleone The
Godfather anyway China was using Hunter
and Joe why because they wanted to
secure a foothold into U.S energy
markets yes China our number one
geopolitical Foe and the bidens helped
them we also know that Chinese Nationals
they have been buying up thousands and
thousands of Acres of Farm and Ranch
Land and other properties that are near
U.S military installations with little
response from the Biden White House we
also know that China of course piloted
that spy balloon over our sensitive
nuclear sites for days virtually no
response from the administration at all
never mind threatening our fighter jets
and international airspace and our Navy
in international waters and now we're
learning about the discovery of an
unauthorized Chinese bio lab that was
operating and has been operating in
California now that was reportedly
performing experiments with dangerous
diseases like HIV malaria covid herpes
and dozens of other infectious agents
the lab which has now since been shut
down was located in a large warehouse
and was filled with blood samples tissue
hazardous waste and infected lab mice
now so far no word from Joe Biden on
that shocking Discovery in fact Joe
really has any tough words for China at
all matter of fact none that I can think
of recently the U.S Navy they were
forced to deploy four destroyers off the
coast of Alaska after an unprecedented
joint Chinese Russian naval operation
nearby what have I been warning about
the new axis of Evil Russia China Iran
no response from Joe Biden that Spire
balloon no response from Joe Biden
hostility against our our military our
Navy our air force and our Ally Taiwan
no response from Joe it appears that the
malignant Communist Party of China can
pretty much do anything they want and
not even hear word one of condemnation
from your commander-in-chief Joe even
sold the Communist Chinese a whopping
900 000 barrels of our oil from our
strategic petroleum reserves this after
millions of people died from covid-19
they've not been held accountable for
that because the pandemic that they
released into the world that happened in
China hunt now China is also waging a
genocide against the minority uyghur
population China is routinely steering
stealing American Technology it's called
intellectual property theft and of
course counterfeiting American Goods
they're even attempting to steal our
coveted seed in agriculture technology
even as we speak they're also constantly
threatening the U.S and our allies
especially Taiwan but despite all of
this Joe Biden cannot seem to muster any
courage to ever call them out in any way
why is that could it be that all the
money Chinese Nationals were paying the
Biden family Syndicate and by the way
why is no one in the media mob concerned
about any of this they never talk about
it it's Donald Trump 24 7 365. in fact
most so-called journalists are more
worried about a Biden impeachment
inquiry in the house and the possibility
that your president is compromised by
the communist Chinese take a look
earlier
[Music]
let me first correct You Were You There
When I said that
okay then what did I say
okay so you're you're claiming that I
said we're going to impeach the
president
floated the idea of impeachment okay so
you're wrong so if you record go back
and watch I said impeachment inquiry
there is a big difference and let me
explain it because maybe not everybody
understands it
would impeachment inquiry does when you
vote on the floor it gives you the Apex
of power of congress this is not saying
impeachment
this is not anything but we need to
investigate if they do not provide the
information we need then we would go to
an impeachment inquiry
impeachment inquiry which simply is an
investigation in providing Congress the
power to do that investigation now it
might help if certain reporters actually
knew anything about the impeachment
process anyway hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else